[Musique]
je sais que le changement peut faire
peur mais il peut aussi nous remplir de
joie de rire
si j'ai appris une chose en rencontrant
une princesse sur un panneau
publicitaire c'est qu'il faut
quelquefois savoir sauter dans le vide
en route vers notre nouvelle vie
[Musique]
bientôt tu seras comme chez toi dans
cette mise en marché rires elle fait
partie de l'aventuré
j'appelle pas ça une aventure j'appelle
ça un terrain miné à terrain illuminé de
promesses d'abord tu
les images on a juste besoin d'un peu de
travaux oui auxerre vont creuser les
douves ajouter une tourelle et un balcon
d'où vous pourrez tous santé ça va être
bien oui
malvina monroe je voudrais bien vendu
cette maison mais je ne gère que des
demeures plus prestigieuses
andes à l'asie est le plus difficile
c'est de réussir à trouver le grand
amour et en semant tout est compliqué
si ce monde n'est pas à ton goût tu n'as
qu'à l'échangé je serai
je souhaite
lourdes une question comment ça se fait
que je souhaite
[Musique]
j'ai fait le souhait de vivre un conte
de fées et tout un marché de travail au
plus tôt à merveille
[Musique]
aux derniers coups de minuit plus rien
ne sera comme autrefois
[Musique]
gisèle qu'avez-vous dont faire
elle est méchante à souhait
[Musique]